الجمهوريون في مجلس النواب الامريكي يقصون
النائبه الديمقراطيه الهام عمر من لجنه
الشؤون الخارجيه بتهمه معاداتها للساميه
جاء بعد نقاش حامد خلاله الديمقراطيون
الجمهوريين بالنفاق والعنصريه وبزدواجيه
المعايير لوجود اعضاء منهم استخدموا ايضا
عبارات تعتبر معاديه للساميه ولم يحاسب
فيما القت عمر خطاب الدفاعيا عن نفسها
[تصفيق]
البعض يرى النساء رئيس مجلس النواب
عمر من اللجنه خطوه رمزيه تشير الى انه
يفي بوعد انتخابيا قطعه سابقا لطردها اذا
فاز الجمهوريون باغلبيه مقاعد مجلس النواب
وكان منكر في اعلن تامين عدد اصوات كافيه
لاستبعاد عمر واكد بعد عزلها انها لا يجب
ان تكون عضوا في اللجنه بسبب تصريحاتها
واضاف ان الجمهوريين لا يقصونها عن باقي
اللجان
فيما يتعلق بالنائب عمر ما قالته من
التعليقات المعاديه للساميه وان الجيش في
امريكا يساوي حماس وطالبان وانه في الحادي
عشر من سبتمبر حدث شيء ما في ذلك اليوم
حتى الرئيس الديمقراطي السابق للجنه يعتقد
ان تعليقاتها كانت خاطئه
الديمقراطيون التهموا سابقا الجمهوريين
بانهم يريدون رد الكيل بمكيالين لطردهم
عضوين جمهوريين عندما الاغلبيه في المجلس
معتبرين ان التحرك لطرد النائبين
الديمقراطيين ادم شافوه من لجنه المخابرات
اضافه الى طرد عمر عملا انتقاميا سياسيا
حسين العربيه واشنطن